as the summer sunshine down upon the
anime community everyone was still
waiting for the next two you hit we all
needed something to turn up the heat for
this anime year but for a certain group
of female fans this summer could not be
hotter
did you guys hear that did I just hear a
ship
the heat could not be hotter this summer
for female yahoo fans with the season a
bless us with shows jam-packed in the
summertime boys only Club shown in
Hollywood gave us a reverse idol show in
homo men attempts to be k-pop stars like
bulla EMT to appease all fancy rage quit
after the ending of the second season in
homo Butler vs. the world Bakumatsu rock
showed us that electric guitars brani
existed in the bucky matzoh era in homer
rock band plays an inch japan traumatic
umana proves that a series based on a
boy love game with all the boiler
elements removed it's just absolute
shite for everyone in homo show with no
homo and love stage had guys worldwide
questioning their boners at the moment
it was revealed at this lovely thin
attractive girl making out with that guy
was in fact another guy
why boner but of course the king of the
French shipping ABS ripping no Girls
Aloud action returned to us in free
eternal female bonus summer giving us
another summer where the wetness just
never ends also moist we were given more
man service more gay tension and of
course we were given officer rinse
lusting his grudge into the wet dreams
of millions of girls worldwide as they
imagine the times when really got a job
in the strip club the time when Haru
dropped the soap it's on when he was at
the VMAs performing at Miley Cyrus whoa
no bad Miley no girls allowed but of
course the best part was yup brother vic
Mignogna got one of yours glasses rin in
the upcoming double bits thousands of
angry tweets posts and even a petition
was started stating that vic Mignogna
was too homophobic because he wouldn't
sign gay dojinshi as if they expected
every class member to be prepared to act
out their own gay fanfiction teens
pissed me in the ass Haruka Nana see vic
Mignogna what did you just iris to me in
the ass Haruka Nana see I'm not really
comfortable with that vic Mignogna
it's not yeah I'm not gonna be with me
and yes it'll connect me in the air who
can all not doing it no make money on a
stop or not and also 2014 also saw the
introduction of studio mapper with their
debut show zankyou no terror and what a
way to announce your presence with a
bang with one of the most beautiful
looking and best directed anime to come
out in the year for an anime about
terrorism few shows can claim the grace
that this show achieved as for all the
big explosions and loud bangs the series
focused loudest during its quietest
moments and it did it amazingly while it
was argued that the writing wasn't
always perfect and the characters
weren't as fleshed out as they could
have been I found myself overlooking it
because I was too immersed Lee
hyper-realistic style and direction
along with a soundtrack that became one
of my favorites of all time the
amazingly tranquil and unique songs that
pulled you into these stunning scenes
that allowed you to just lose yourself
in them I could spend hours alone just
talking about how amazing the soundtrack
is itself so let's just take a moment to
just appreciate sounds the most
beautiful part of this OST is join to
make what oh that's right in the rest of
the summer season we got some
cannibalistic fighting fun in the horror
anime Tokyo ghoul and boy was this a
horror the horror the horror the horror
of not being able to see [ __ ]
anything yes due to the censorship a lot
of the more violent scenes were blacked
out leaving the audience gasping yeah
absolutely goddamn nothing though most
importantly we were given this year
striking bachelor in Sookie Yama that's
right ladies he had it all he knows how
to give you a great date eat you out
properly and he doesn't care no matter
what time of the month it is he might
also be a pedophile rail wards gave us
an original concept by giving us a show
not about wars or rails but about trains
yes only trains isn't that amazing I
like trains you like trains I [ __ ]
love trains who doesn't love trains you
should like trains why do you like
trains everyone should love trains this
is a char bar trains one of the most
hotly disputed series is here turned out
to be Alden o0 not just because of the
troll cliffhanger anything they got
everyone talking but also because of the
great character rivalry that drove
everyone on message boards into a frenzy
on one side he had team in a hoe a
badass pilot who has the incredible
philosophy of keep calm and well just
keep calm someone who always has the
answers whether he's happy sad angry
scared thinking surprised constipated
Kristen Stewart's his mother [ __ ] got
it all and on the other side of the
spectrum we had team Slade a man who's
essentially just bad luck Brian
disguised as an anime character a
character so hilariously unlucky let me
to show you a typical day in the life of
slaves
much to my dismay the strangely tart of
Barack Aman was not a show about Barack
Obama evolving to a Digimon but was
instead a light-hearted feel-good show
about self-discovery set in the
countryside starring a likeable car sigh
groan you of children and actually act
like children
aka their annoying little [ __ ] or
adorable little kids who just want to
take care of gekkan shoujo nozaki [ __ ]
gave some light-hearted fun in girl gets
friendzone a 12-episode show a show
which looks boring on paper but actually
surprised the anime community yeah being
a genuinely funny show that pokes fun at
the javanese tropes singing in a shoujo
genre many fans were excited for PA
works next show glass limb a stunningly
lucky to splice a live show that was a
bit of a letdown because literally
nothing happens this I would like to
show a preview of my newest parody
episodes glass leap abridged episode one
literally nothing virtual reality gaming
fun return to us in sword art online
modern warfare 2 giving us more of the
same Opie hacking [ __ ] from the main
character that was actually somewhat
entertaining our points study when this
doesn't at least sound fun yeah sword
art online setting Call of Duty where
Kirito who is now a girl becomes a Jedi
Master fighting in a battle royale style
tournament against Darth Vader with a
lead heroine you can use mid-air 720
quickscopes while coming with ninety
percent more camel toes [ __ ] lighten
up a sake but why would curry toe bring
a saw to a gunfight cuz he just lives
life on the edge living on the edge
living on the edge
wait a minute that's no edge it's just a
karma go kill yes a karma go kill reared
its ugly head to split the Atome
community with literally the edgy ER
show in history a show which managed to
mix in extremely violent and bloody
content with a story seemingly written
by trihard rebellious teenager
attempting to impress the cool older
kids hauling in their skin with wounds
that will not heal but honestly I don't
know why fans got so defensive when the
show was criticized I mean let's be
honest the show was pretty bad right
guys guys
as the fall season came about there was
anticipation in the air with a season of
hype coming about many fans were excited
for many things but in all this chaos
chance could be hard from afar estudio i
am the bone of my wallet hi is my body
and money is my blood I have wasted over
a thousand million yet unknown to team
no to j.c.staff
have withstood CG dragons you create
crabby spin-offs yet they will never
satisfy the fake fans so as I spend
unlimited budget new fate gracelessly
season from the godly studio of you
photo ball who proved their dominance
once again by raising the bar of
animation in a TV production featuring
arguably some of the best-looking action
sees in any TV series people are left
wondering how deep their pockets were to
be able to make such production every
single frame of this is so beat fully
crafted you can feel the money just
bleeding out in every cut well I guess
they just like to make it rain all the
time
ah yeah but of all you make it rain make
it rain all over this production you
football oh yeah just like that baby
yeah baby you can make it rain all over
this production okay anime got its own
version of invaders of the body splashes
in parasites too Maxim a sci-fi horror
action show featuring a main character
with a right hand that can literally
shape-shift into anything no he doesn't
masturbate with it a very well-rounded
show featuring some great animation an
interesting story but unfortunately is a
ruined in some 10 themes due to the
dubstep soundtrack that makes it hard
for me to take seriously because this is
honestly what I see when it kicks in
Oh
classical music nerds were given their
classical music boners in your line
April I show that just about cells and
everything is doing so fun it's amazing
in more than one way it really has
everything going for it from a touching
story heartfelt characters gripping
romances and concert scenes so well done
and beautifully executed you'd find
yourself clapping along to recorded
performances despite the fact that it
was a fake concert and most people have
no interest in classical music
whatsoever
apparently Tokyo ghoul wasn't bad enough
as terraformers perfected the art of
censorship so bad it turned ridiculously
hilarious with this in mind I would like
to present the hands professional guide
to censoring like terraformers step 1
open up ms paint step 2
censor all paths we don't want the
kitties to see in black step 3
that's the ship complete you now have a
completely family-friendly Shores
Shiro Barker gave us a very interesting
insight into the inner workings of anime
productions by giving us four was
essentially an animated documentary in
making animes featuring some characters
who are modeled after real people in the
industry it showed us that even a
professional production mimics every
group project you've ever done in school
there's the one who does not not send
the work the one who has no idea what's
going on
the one who says they're gonna do work
but doesn't the two who bicker about
irrelevant [ __ ] and gets nothing done
and the only time that anyone has ever
productive is the night before the
deadline sudeer mapper continued their
track record of visually stunning and
well directed shows with shingeki no
Bahamas being based entirely on a card
game up audiences wanted what kind of
yugioh ripoff this would be but instead
what they got was the Pirates of the
Caribbean ask fancy adventure show that
was directed in a similar fashion to
that scene in Hollywood blockbuster
films localization returned to give us
yet another year of
featuring the MMO game where the most
important skill you could ever possess
is pushing your glasses slightly up it
continued right way left off with a
well-thought-out world that was far
better written than it was animated and
all he was really missing with some
crazy Korean commentary to spice up the
PvP battle scenes
okay
this is also an important year for
long-running show names as hunter x
hunter finally finishes four-year run
treating us to some of the finest
offerings that shown in genre has ever
seen
whether you're a shounen fan or not this
was one of the top shows to come out
2014 as a sports an amazingly well
developed world characters and plot that
relies on far more than your usual -
action you see in shown in and on the
other side of the spectrum the route of
the last movie came out via ters
coinciding with the final chapter being
published marking the end of an era as
kids can no long again hinges confused
with overpowered majors pricing magic
with sign language in the mainstream
media had soon meq made her debut on
u.s. national television on the David
Letterman Show performing in front of an
audience who had no idea what they were
looking at and a bewildered David
Letterman who was probably thinking look
at her she she whoever me huh what the
[ __ ] is up with these journeys go tunes
and finally from a creator of Evangelion
himself came a short film which took
over the enemy community for a while in
mimimi the sure that everyone initially
dismissed his porn that became that
weird video you showed to your friends
for a reaction that became the too deep
for your discussion that came with
anything Hideki analogous with reactions
ranging from hits fapping time see this
is why I don't watch anime yeah yeah
yeah oh oh dancer huh still fapping done
that's a nipple film is actually already
it's a lifestyle it's not really about
the nudity plays a deeper message for
the girls being a symbol about the
inherent dangers of being obsessed with
2d anime unborn hashtag JustFab eaters
don't ask me
I've got no [ __ ] clue whatever it
meant to you it cemented the year that
gave us more [ __ ] waifu's more dandy
more plot more trains more poop our Ward
sheikha more day life pedophilia more
edge more vocaloids more motive enemy
stands more boys more counting planets
warmest pronunciations of brynhilda more
games no life more 911 bait more smelly
periods more pong more guys playing with
their balls more girls playing with that
you're more gay overtones more gay
overtone more more more gang overtones
and just more gay more slain babe more
cooler duty [ __ ] more MLG sound rags
less CG dragons more trips on the few
trains more girls being friend-zoned
more shindeki not Kyojin more mspaint
censorship more years that's more
database more David Letterman being
confuses [ __ ] war controversial cleavage
and many more great years of animate
succumb that was 2014 in anime so thank
you well good night wait what do you
mean New Year's was months ago I was
meant to get this video out then what's
the date now ah son of bub oh hey Giga
great job for getting this bill up three
months late ha ha ah shut up
hey guys gig ok I hope you enjoyed that
3 monthly video if you are interested in
any of the anime I talked about this
video then I made a list in the
description below but as always most of
them are available on crunchyroll so you
can go to crunchyroll.com slash yeah my
zone for a free month of premium
membership also I'm sorry for the lack
of videos recently I have been busy with
a job this past year long other
distractions yeah but don't worry I
definitely have not given up or died or
anything of the sort
I'm still making videos but my schedule
might be a bit longer than it used to be
but I hope you guys still single me till
then so until then I thinking of and
I'll see you guys next time